ALBERT REYNAUD: Hi, everyone.
Thank you for being here.
I hope you are all
comfortably seated.
So my name is Albert Reynaud.
I work in the Android and Play
Business Development team,
looking after app
developers across Europe,
and I'm based in London.
So today, as you
heard this morning,
we've been kind of
announcing a few things.
And we're kind of excited of
do all these announcements.
We've been working really
hard over the past few months
of bring--
keep on innovating
within the console,
trying to bring
new tools, trying
to bring new functionalities
so you can then come back home
and also start innovating.
So we are really excited
about having you here.
I hope you're enjoying
your stay in Valene.
your day so far.
And as you can see in
this innovation track,
got a pretty packed agenda.
We're going to start talking
about machine learning
slash assistance topics.
And then we're going
to discuss VR and have
some kind of panel discussions.
And we're finished with
sharing insights and research
findings about design.
So let's start with
the first presentation
focused on machine learning that
I will be presenting together
with Daniel from Memrise
and Hashim from IM.
So earlier this
morning, Harsim gave you
a presentation about
machine learning, giving you
an overview of the key
principles of machine learning,
as well as why we believe at
Google that this is important.
In this session we'll try to
have a slightly different angle
and try to give you insight
on the how as a developer,
you should be approaching
it and thinking about it
and also how some of your
peers have been approaching it
recently within the app.
So I know that machine learning,
artificial intelligence, you
probably hear a lot about it.
A lot of people talk about it.
It's probably one of the
top buzz word of 2017.
Probably a lot less people
are actually really doing
and I'm sure that many of you
are kind of excitingly confused
about it.
But if you're here at least that
means that you are interested.
Who in the room
is actually doing
some kind of machine learning
related project within the app?
OK so we got like
maybe good 20%.
And who is considering it
for the next six, 12 months?
So we got up to 50%.
I hope that the end
of this talk, we're
going to have more than 50%.
But that's great.
So in any case, as
Harsim mentioned,
machine learning has become the
number one priority for Google.
We're moving from a mobile first
world towards a AI first world.
And the way I think
about it is sometimes
kind of thinking about
five 10 years ago,
all these companies that were
not really considering mobile
seriously in their strategy.
Right?
And actually, the
success of many of you
is linked to the fact that all
traditional players were not
taking into their
strategy mobile seriously.
And we hope that
you're not going
to do the same mistake with
machine learning today.
So machine learning
already a reality as we
saw this morning from
kind of image recognition
in Google Photos, content
recommendation on YouTube.
Over 100 production
ready projects
are actually using neural
network technology at Google.
But you probably thinking right
now, yes, right this is great.
But how does that
apply to me, right?
I'm not Google.
I don't have the resources.
I don't have the
skills to do it.
How should I be
thinking about it?
And how should I
even get started?
So during this
presentation we're
going to try to get look
at the key aspects you
should be considering
when thinking
about machine learning.
And starting by thinking, OK,
are you machine learning ready?
OK so what are the key initial
conditions before taking up
a machine learning project?
So first of all, do
you have a problem?
Sounds a bit silly.
But this is probably one
of the most common mistake
we observe in industry.
People are looking
at what ML can
do and try to kind of randomly
apply that to their business.
However, you should take the
problem the other way around.
You should look
at your problems--
and not simple problem like
mission critical problems--
and try to see how
machine learning can
help you solve these problems.
This is important
because you might end up
building a great model, super
successful machine learning
feature.
But it's useless because it's
not actually solving a problem
within your company.
Once you have a problem,
obviously, you need data.
You need a lot of data.
You need a lot of quality
data, large volume.
And you need to be able to kind
of access it and process it
at scale.
So that means that
you might have
to go through a
process of improvement
of your infrastructure.
You might have to
clean your data.
And you have to either think
about collecting labels
for your data.
And finally, you
need to identify
the people that are going
to execute this project
within your companies.
And if you don't have
anyone, please don't feel
discouraged right away.
They are a lot of
resources online
that are available to
everyone to train your teams.
Of course there are UDCity,
YouTube and all that kind of--
GitHub et cetera, et cetera.
There's a lot of resources out
there that you can leverage.
But ideally, in an ideal world,
what tend to recommend it's
to combine two types of skills.
On one hand, what we
call data scientists.
So people that are able to kind
of conceptualize mathematical
model that kind of takes
into account your business
requirements.
And on the other side, what
we call data engineers that
translate this into code,
are able to train the model,
and to run it on production.
So at the beginning,
obviously, you're
going to be kind of tapping into
whatever resources you have.
But the more you
grow, the more we
encourage you to think
about structuring this team
into centralized
team that is then
going to diffuse their knowledge
into the different division
and process of the organization.
So now you have a clear problem.
You have skills.
You have data.
You need to start thinking
about choosing your model.
Harsim this morning mentioned,
kind of described a few of them
from image classification
to reinforcement learning
within self-driving cars.
You need to choose your
model and even maybe
a combination of several models.
And it's often where
the magic happens.
One key aspect of it
is the presence or not
of labels within your data.
So in the example of
image recognition,
you might have data
that will tell you
the object that is present
within your image, right?
But unfortunately, often
this might not be the case.
In this case, you
might have to consider
starting to collect
these labels or even
think about choosing
another model that will not
require these labels.
A lot of companies in the
machine learning field
believe in what we
call open research.
So including Google,
including DeepMind,
we believe in open research.
This means that a
lot of the research
finding, a lot of the libraries,
a lot of the models being
developed are being published
online, available open source
to everyone.
This means that as
a developer, you
would have to choose between
to what extension you will rely
on existing models
and to what extent
you will actually
develop your own models.
So obviously at the
beginning we encourage
you to tap as much as you can
into our existing libraries
that are built.
But quickly, you might realize
that this doesn't really
fit exactly your needs.
And you might have to
either train your own model
with your own data, or even
build your own custom model.
As far as Google
is concerned, we
have this trade off
between simplicity
and flexibility will
also kind of determine
what technological
kind of solution
you're going to be using.
So as Google is
concerned, we can help you
along the whole spectrum
with under ready to use side
of the spectrum,
we got solutions
like Google Cloud Machine
Learning APIs, which gives you
Cloud Vision, speech,
and translates,
and natural language of APIs,
as well as Action on Google
that we're going
to be discussing
in the next presentation.
But if this is not enough,
one of the most commonly used
framework by developer
is TensorFlow.
Harsim mentioned
it this morning.
It has become the most common
use machine learning framework.
You can use it to build
your own custom model.
You can use it to
train your own model.
You have a lot of libraries
available out there.
You can kind of run it on
different processing units
on different Cloud
platform etc, cetera.
And as Harsim
mentioned this morning
we're going to be launching
soon TensorFlow Lite, which
will enable running machine
learning models directly
on device.
With this, I will pass it
over to Memorize and IM,
to Daniel and Harsim who are
going to share with you how
they are doing approaching
machine learning
within their own app.
Thank you very much.
DANIEL ZOHAR: Hello.
Hi.
So thank you very much, Albert.
And thank you for
having us here.
I think it's an
amazing conference.
Thank you very much.
So right.
So my name is Daniel,
I'm the CT of Memrise.
And if you don't Memrise, we're
one of the leading language
learning apps in the world, with
over 25 million users and 200
language combinations
to learn from.
We really strive
to make language
learning as joyful and
effective as possible.
And very recently we won
the best app on Google Play.
We're very proud of
this achievement.
And today I'd like
to talk to you
about how we build product
feature using machine learning.
So I think Albert asked you guys
how many people are interested
or playing around
with using machine
learning to be a product.
But how many of you actually
have delivered a product
using machine learning?
Right, so not as many.
So it's obvious
that everybody is
really excited about the
possibilities of machine
learning.
But it's not as easy to get
from having ideas and using
technology to get
something out there.
So we doing hackathons
on a regular basis,
like every six weeks.
And we really want
to give people
time to play around with ideas
and technologies they think
might work well in the product.
And this particular
feature started as a hack.
So we try to think,
OK, so what can we
do with object recognition?
And after a couple of
days with developer
playing around with
that, they came up
with a very neat concept,
which is turning the world
into its own dictionary.
So imagine taking your
phone, looking around,
and if you learn German,
then you look at the screen.
You learn how to say
screen or TV in German.
And that was the idea.
So once we had that in
place, after the hack,
we thought, OK,
this is really cool.
How can we take this and
actually make this something
that we can give to our users?
So then we started
looking at the product
and tried to define it better.
And what we knew we
want to have-- we
want to make sure that it
is very accurate, because we
teach people languages.
We can't the wrong thing.
It has to be the right
difficulty level.
And it has to be really
fast and give like, oh wow.
This is amazing.
Really bringing the
technology forward.
The interesting thing
is that actually getting
machine learning model in
this particular case object
recognition was
really the easy part.
The most difficult
part was to get it
to recognize the right things.
So if you guys look at
that picture, what you see?
So a guy, a man.
if I look at that
picture, actually, I
see James, who's one
of the people that
worked on this project.
Now we took this
image and we gave it
to Google Vision ARP, which is
an amazing piece of technology.
And this is what
it came up with.
So hair, facial hair, beard.
Well, this picture is
definitely very much fun.
But I think that's not the
first thing when we look
at the picture, we think it.
So I think context is
really, really important.
It's not about
recognizing object,
it's recognizing
the right objects.
And we spend most of the
time really focusing on that.
So once after playing
around with a lot of models,
and there are quite
a few out there,
we actually decide to
train our own model.
So the base was
using Inception V3,
which is a model which exists.
On top of that, we
trained our model.
So what we actually did
is we got product managers
to collect a lot of images.
We first defined the
images that we care about.
So we do a lot of user surveys.
We try to understand how
our users use the app.
And we know that often
time, for example, they
use it at their homes.
So we thought, well, OK.
So which objects
are available in
their immediate surroundings?
So we try to define
that list of objects,
which were in the 100s.
And then start
collecting the images.
And actually, our
product manager
spend out of time collecting
images from different sources.
And we found out
that, actually, we
need quite a few examples,
like some objects needed more
than others.
For example, people's
eyes you can see here,
there is one example has
a suggestion here which
is not quite the hairdryer.
Maybe he needs one so this was
an example of something which
was a bit difficult.
And as you can see there,
there is a picture of a bicycle
and the picture of glasses.
And they're both recognized
as glasses, something
that we wouldn't imagine
that-- you would never
look at the bicycle
and say its glasses.
But it's actually
problems that emerge.
And we had to do a
lot of back and forth,
collecting more and
more images, focusing
on amateur photography,
and also different sizes
and shapes of the objects
that we really cared about.
So there are a lot of
interesting examples,
as you can see in the slides,
where there were problems.
But by iterating
and understanding
what it is that we
want to build and what
we care about being
the final result,
we came up with a
really neat product.
So these are just a few images
from the finished product that
actually recognized really nice
things like airplanes and stuff
like that.
And now we're in the process of
finding out how to integrate it
best with our product.
So just a few lessons
learned, I think like I said,
I think even with a
really good model,
different data sets really
equal different products.
So like we saw in the
Google Vision API,
it's not that it was wrong.
It just didn't give us
what we wanted it to be.
We really cared in our product.
We wanted people to look
around them and learn
how objects are
called, so really
cared about single objects, how
the user is experiencing it.
And additionally to
that, I just want
to say that I think,
machine learning--
I think as Albert said
as well-- it's a tool.
You want to educate
people on how to use it.
There's a lot of
resources out there.
Educate your teams and try
to encourage them to use it.
And try to find
the right problems
that machine learning can solve.
Thank you very much.
And I'll hand it over
to Harsim from IM.
HARSIMRAT SANDHAWALIA: Morning.
So we're going to talk about
how we use machine learning
at IM to help improve our
workflow for the photographers.
And what is IM?
So IM is a combination
of our community.
So these are our
photographers, we
have around 20
million photographers
who upload their content
onto our platform.
And we also have a
marketplace where
people can sell
their photographs
for Live Think,
which can be used
by brands for their PR
campaign or advertisement.
And to connect the
right photographer
with the right buyer and
we build the technology.
And the technology we
build is called IM Vision.
So the IM Vision focuses
on understanding everything
about a photograph.
So what's inside a photograph?
There's a dog jumping,
a dog leaping, a stick,
a frozen lake,
atmosphere, outdoors.
But we also want to know
how good the photograph is
composed.
How did that photograph uploaded
by any person on the web
compare to the photographs taken
by professional photographers?
And that's what we captured
through aesthetics.
So we have a deep learning
model, a machine learning
model, which can rate a
photograph a score between 0
and 100.
100 means that it is as
good by a professional photo
photographer.
And so the core of training
any machine learning model
is the problem.
The problem is the
problem you want to solve.
And a machine learning
model needs an objective.
And objective, in
this case, would
be given a collection of
images, give me the right answer
that I expect.
And when you don't give
me the right answer,
go correct yourself.
So this is the feedback that
the machine learning model gets.
And as you can imagine, the
more complicated your problem,
the more complex your
model needs to be.
And that complexity
usually translates
into the size of the model
in megabytes or gigabytes.
And that's a concern when
you want to go mobile.
So if you want to run machine
learning model on mobile,
you are constrained on the
size of the machine learning
model a phone can run
on a CPU or a GPU.
So that's an
additional constraint
that the model has
to take into account.
You can actually take
an existing large scale,
big complexity model
and then shrink it
down to the size you want.
There are many
methods out there.
Quantization and
compression is one.
An analogy would be changing
a PND image into a JPEG image,
for all practical purposes.
Their visual quality is
similar, but the more attention
you pay to the detail, you
start to see the cracks.
And this is all and well.
Once you have a
machine learning model
that can run on the phone, it
can produce all the information
we need to know about an image.
You can detect the
tags, you can detect
what's inside the photograph,
but you can also get a score--
a score how good the
photo the photograph
is composed compared to
professional photographers.
And once we have all
of the information,
the question is you can send
all the photographs to a AWS
machine or a Google Cloud and
get all the answers you want.
Why bother your miniaturizing
your machine learning model?
What's the advantage?
Why spend so much effort
into something that
is already working for you?
One key aspect is privacy.
So in our case, we are
working with people's
personal collection.
So it's your personal photos.
It could be photos
of your partners.
It could be pictures of your
kids or private moments.
And it's very tedious to upload
the whole of your collection
to Cloud and get it
analyzed by the algorithm.
And the second key aspect
is that the current
functionalities that multiple
people upload their photos
and they go to a single server.
But with mobile phones, we
have a perfect scenario.
We have one user and
one computing machine--
the handheld device.
And the third reason is
it's available everywhere.
You don't need to be
connected to the internet.
You don't need to have Wi-Fi.
And that makes sense, because
taking example of machine
translation, you need
the translation the most
when you're traveling abroad
when you don't have access
to Instant or Wi-Fi.
So you want your
machine learning model
to be to be able
to run everywhere.
So if you are a machine learning
engineer or a data scientist,
that's your part of the problem.
But this is a
problem half solved.
Now it's the product
manager's turn
to turn that into a feature.
And that goes through
various cycles.
Once you have a prototype-- that
could come through a hackathon,
that could come through
an internal effort--
you build the first prototype.
And you let the
PMs play with it.
And they can think
about how they
can use this machine
learning model in a feature.
And that's the place where
either your client's team
Android iOS and the
designer come together
to build a specific feature.
The next step is actually
getting user feedback.
So let real users of the app or
the feature play with the model
and get their feedback.
And this is the critical
part of actually retraining
your machine learning model.
And collect a new data set.
That new data set should
reflect the feedback
that you get from real users.
And the next stage is actually
retraining your machine
learning model to better fit.
With that in mind, we launched
a feature a few months ago,
called EyeEm selects, which
runs our deep learning
models on the phone.
It analyzes all your
photo collection.
You could have
thousands of photos.
And then it suggest what
the best pictures you
should upload to the platform.
This makes sense.
You don't want to upload
your private photos.
And also if you're
a new user to IM,
you see all the good photos
and good photographers,
and you get intimidated.
What should I upload?
Am I good enough?
This machine
learning model helps
us help them find
the best photos they
can upload onto our platform.
And this entirely
runs on TensorFlow.
We haven't yet moved
to TensorFlow Lite.
But it's going to
come very soon.
If you have a machine
learning model
you can assess its performance
by various metrics.
There is precision
recall, toughen accuracy.
But you also want to
measure the performance
based on how well your
target feature is.
And in our case, we
wanted the users to upload
not just more photos,
but also better photos.
And so when a user
uploads a photo that
is recommended by a
machine learning model,
we automatically add a hashtag
to it called #EyeEmselects.
And then we assess
how does that photos
with that hashtag
compared to everything
else we how in our platform.
And we saw that people
were actually uploading
better content over time.
I think that's it.
If you have questions
for us, please feel
free.